the jurgen experience yeah i know that
the music business was way way different
than it is now it's so different i don't
know if those two things are related but
yeah i'm sure the peace movement it
probably saw a lot of wild [ __ ] well
he's a musician right and the music
business is what you survive in and for
example elvis you know the way that he
his life ended and and uh you know the
way that the music business was back
then it was you know throw throw drugs
at the problem throw sex and money at
the problem and um i don't know that uh
had he had
modern management or
even if he was with you know somebody
who um you know like a handler you know
that would say hey it's probably not a
good idea for you to say that
you know nowadays we have people who um
are
their their sole jobs are to help keep
us from you know stepping on it you know
right so
and i've got people around me they used
to be real busy with me but you know
fortunately growing up i've learned a
lot of stuff that you know you can can't
say so well specifically i mean
in this day and age with social media
it's so easy for someone to just tweet
something really ridiculous
without someone
saying hey don't [ __ ] say that you're
on adderall sit down don't write that
down don't say that you know it's just
back then
do you think that the the drug and
alcohol thing is the same today in music
or do you think it's less do you think
it's just not promoted by
i mean how what do you think the
difference is between the influence of
drugs and alcohol in the early days
versus now well i think i think in the
early days of the music business first
off the drugs weren't as strong and
you know they didn't have
like for example something as simple as
herb
you know the the marijuana that that i
used to smoke when i was a kid versus
what's
being manufactured and grown nowadays is
way different
and
i think that the stigmatism for people
about smoking is less and i i think that
there's a lot of
other things that people use out on the
road to to cope with things that could
be dealt with with you know good
management good good support system um
and and most importantly you know having
somebody's going to tell you the truth
you know i'm a grown up i'm a big boy so
when when i have stuff happen in my
career
and um it could have been avoided or or
somebody didn't tell me and i find out
later that sucks yeah and and for a lot
of people when that stuff happens they
respond in a negative way with
you know
either self-sabotage or or you know they
medicate themselves and and i remember
back when i was drinking um you know i
there was a thing someone said at one of
those meetings and i thought it was kind
of clever the guy said you know i drank
when my team won and i drank when my
team lost and i drank when my team
played i drank when my team was in the
off season and i thought all right well
that's that's about me what team are we
not rooting for anymore so but you know
there's so many reasons why people
make it or don't make it in the music
business and i think much like yourself
you know in our
getting to know each other earlier this
afternoon um
you know you have to take care of
yourself you really really do and and
there's so many things in in the music
industry that that um you know the the
history the uh
the the people that you're working with
you know a lot of people don't want to
say anything bad about somebody but i
mean imagine how much better things
would be if somebody really said you
know what he's a nice guy but he stole
from us or you know this guy is he he's
good at this but he's terrible at that
you know everybody's afraid to offend
anybody with with stuff like that but
yet you know in other areas of life
offending people doesn't mean [ __ ] you
know so we we've had some times that
we've had some people on our on our uh
crew
and um
tours that we've been on the last tour
we were on not my band but another band
their bus drove right up to the canadian
border and the driver got out and left
them all sitting there
[Music]
so yeah it's a music business because he
had a dui or something like that and you
can't get up into canada so oh my god
that's hilarious they're so convoluted
all this stuff but see like back in the
day you know uh back in the 60s or 70s i
was talking about you know different
eras different messes different managers
you know managers used to manage the
mess they don't manage the message
anymore they don't want to tolerate that
[ __ ] because there's always somebody
around the corner that's ready to work
harder than you it's like that
motivational thing that arnold said a
long time somebody's out there getting
stronger
running farther you know all that stuff
i love those motivational tapes
yeah well someone is out there doing it
and if you do [ __ ] up and you want to
just take xanax all day and and do coke
and you don't write new music someone's
going to come along
and
unfortunately everybody that but that's
isn't that a part of like the whole rock
and roll mystique part of the whole
mystique was the guy who did crazy drugs
it was kind of half out of it but go on
stage and be brilliant sometimes you
know that's the keith moon you know yeah
that's that worked for keith but i think
that's you know player like keith is so
all over the place you know he doesn't
have a song with a pattern so let's just
go out there and and just hit everything
um there i i know of a lot of musicians
that that
um will drink when they play i i know a
lot that don't
i don't know very many anymore that do
drugs um that's just something that's
been kind of
kind of phased out yeah just because you
know impact it has in your body well not
only that but the things that it makes
the people do and and the kind of people
that are around that i think that you
know like again like i was saying herb
is less of astigmatism so people are a
little bit more open with that but you
know as far as
coming backstage and it's smelling like
you know somebody's back there burning
chemicals or something like that or you
know people falling out in the hallway
from heroin or you know tweaking around
on meth or coke or something you know we
we try and and
associate with people that are
like-minded with us you know the people
that are about their careers and that
really are uh into taking care of
themselves um two of the guys in five
finger death punch dude
they have uh uh sensei out with them we
all are doing jiu jitsu um when we were
out with trivium the singer for that
band does to jesus so we try and hang
out with bands that are really uh
health-centric you know that are really
really looking into and not just from
here down but here up to
when you when you were a kid and you
first were hearing about bands and
getting into bands
was that
was that always a narrative was that
something that was discussed a lot that
like a lot of bands did drugs
i don't think it was because it you know
it wasn't something we were preoccupied
with we were at the time when i first
started playing around by myself with
other little you know small time uh
outfits and stuff like that and it never
was really drugs per se it would be like
maybe get a six pack of air and you know
maybe smoke a joint or something but it
wasn't until mega death actually um got
going and we met uh
gar
and uh
some of the people in that circle where
we you know started to experiment with
other stuff and
and we had a manager at the time who who
was very very bad off and um he would
try to always keep us
loaded and we ended up having to fire
the guy because it was for our own
health
our own safety i mean you know if i was
a cheap bastard and didn't have any
money i would say this is great you got
for free but you know the thing was is
um you know the guy was keeping
several members of the band sick
yeah there's guys that do that there are
guys that do that and there's guys that
that'll do that just to sort of corral
you and keep control of you i've seen
managers do that
brian wilson story was a great story too
what what happened with brian wilson
the movie that he had about the doctor
that he had he had some psychiatrists
that kept him all whacked out i watched
the movie that paul paul garganimous or
whatever his name is the one guy from
billions was uh the doctor
and i can't remember who played brian
wilson but it was a great movie what is
it called uh it was the brian wilson
story i guess i don't know i i haven't
seen that one yet but john cusack played
it and i know john cusack uh
practitioner too he he'd trained over
with cincy benny at the jet center too
yeah i remember in he used him in one of
his movies
there it is love and mercy that's it
giamatti paul giamatti yeah oh yeah the
guy from the howard stern movie too that
guy's awesome
yeah that um
that's that whole thing with uh
psychiatrists or doctors or uh you know
whether it's a manager or someone that
you have that can get you drugs and that
keeps you on them that's a long standing
story that's been going on a long time
especially like with really talented
people a lot of times that that person
that they can benefit financially from
controlling them so they get a hold up
they go look i'm just going to babysit
you keep you on drugs and then suck
money out of you and and then there's a
lot of those guys that wind up keeping
these incompetent managers for years
longer than they should because the guy
gets them drugs too right because the
guy gets them girls he gets some drugs
he sets up parties he does all the stuff
that doesn't help the band it doesn't
help their music right but it helps keep
him around the picture yeah
those guys are real i've met those guys
in comedy too they exist they exist
and it's um
you know it's always been a long story
uh long-standing story in comedy you
know with uh
sam kinnison was in the coke and richard
pryor famously had a problem but you
don't you only hear about those kind of
people when they make the news you know
when something happened so i was always
wondering like back in your day when you
first started like was that a trope was
that something that was discussed a lot
with rock stars
no the drugs the drug thing because it
seems like so many guys from from your
era we're doing drugs yeah they were uh
well let's
i'll give you a scenario when we got
signed to capital we went up into the
tower we went into one of the little
rooms here and the guy slid his desk
open and there were lines everywhere so
yeah they gave us a box of nike shoes
and all the blow you could eat wow
that's crazy yeah
when i was a kid when i worked at a
comedy club they offered me coke or
money
or a combination of both you get paid in
cash or coke
this is crazy
i heard i heard about a band uh with a
front man that i really respected that
wanted to be paid in
crack and and
i just thought you know what i've lost
all respect for you now well maybe new
could get it at a good price and sell it
on the road yeah you never know it's
hard to get good crack
yeah there's a lot of people that get
like really lost on drugs
but that's why i'm always happy to speak
with a person like yourself that's you
know had your problems and put them
aside and bounced back yeah and you know
got healthy and and and is open about it
you know i think that's it's so
important for guys to hear it's also got
that it's a trap too
that you can get you get sucked up into
that tribe you can be a good person a
solid person who's you know got
confidence you can accomplish things but
you can get still sucked in that truck
you can